[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce nouveau numéro du sky
échos le magazine qui vous racontent la
vie des acteurs économiques du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes à guyancourt dans le futur
qg de la software république
cette démarche d'open innovation à
l'initiative du groupe renault en
collaboration avec quatre autres
industriels
objectif développer la mobilité de
demain c'est au programme de ce 15e
numéro du sky et qu ils vont réfléchir à
des solutions pour la mobilité du futur
le groupe renault avec atos dassault
systèmes stmicroelectronics et d'alès se
sont associés dans la software
république le siège sera installé à
saint quentin en yvelines 420 m²
supplémentaires pour antemeta cette
société guyancourt toi spécialisée dans
le digital va aussi embauché 55 nouveaux
collaborateurs pour développer son
activité
enfin l'école de 1600 ouvrira ses portes
en septembre 2021 à proximité du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
établissement spécialisé dans la
formation métiers de la cybersécurité
[Musique]
à
le puget les dents dans sur le plateau
de saclay et sur le plateau de saclay il
ya beaucoup d'entre nous qui sont
présents et il faut imaginer la soft
république comme une espèce de
laboratoire géant en plein air avec à
côté des labos des outils de simulation
que ça c'est ça la beauté aussi des
choses c'était le 9 avril dernier le
directeur général du groupe renault
lucas di méo et les dirigeants d'atos de
dassault systèmes de stmicroelectronics
et de thales ont présenté la sorte way
république
une collaboration entre ces grands
groupes industriels pour développer les
services et les solutions de la mobilité
de demain et ils ont officialisé
l'emplacement du qg de la software et
public c'est ici même dans le bâtiment
odyssée situé à côté du technocentre de
guyancourt
une démarche d'open innovation qui va
permettre de mettre en commun
l'expertisé de chacun que ce soit dans
la big data la cybersécurité le digital
l'automobile ou encore les composants
électroniques les détails de cette
initiative industrielle inédite avec
françois dosse 1 pour le groupe renault
et pierre barnabé pour atos
[Musique]
ce retrait république et heures un
groupe qui agrège les compétences très
complémentaire de cinq grands acteurs
[Musique]
c'est une opportunité l'opportunité de
travailler les logiciels les logiciels
qui vont être le coeur de la valeur
future de la mobilité
[Musique]
chacun des cinq acteurs apporte sa
pierre à l'édifice dans un système ya
bien sûr les acteurs membres fondateurs
qui ont été annoncés mais également des
start up des centres de recherche des
universités qui ensemble vont travailler
dans ce nouveau monde digital de la
mobilité
les voitures seront effectivement des
capteurs des absorbeurs des générateurs
de données renault va apporter à ce
programme de la soirée publique et bien
le véhicule finalement c'est qui est un
peu un petit peu notre force mais
également le travail sur les nouvelles
mobilités et atos dans le domaine les
compétences autour du calcul en calcul
intensif de plus en plus miniaturisés
embarqué autour de la sécurisation des
objets donc des voitures et de
l'environnement qui le tour l'idée est
que ces nouvelles mobilités soit
décarbonée aujourd'hui ces émissions
dues aux transports représentent 23 %
des gaz à effet de serre et le travail
de la software république va nous
pousser à descendre ce ce chiffre le
plus bas possible que la voiture devient
objet digital et s'assurer que dans
cette
dans cet environnement informationnel la
voiture évolue de manière sécurisée
les équipes travaillent déjà ensemble
mais maintenant on va les réunir dans un
même lieu
qui est ce qui s'appelle le bâtiment
odyssée sur le technocentre sur le
plateau de saclay donc avec la proximité
des centres de recherche des grandes
universités des équipes qui
travailleront en fonction des besoins et
de manière totalement flexible et
ouverte
et effectivement on ira puiser dans les
équipes des différentes des niches
industrielles participants et on sera
tous ensemble l'idée est de le faire
ensemble de travailler ensemble sur des
projets clairement identifiés ça sera
vraiment au fur à mesure que les projets
avanceront que l'on mettra plus ou moins
les équipes de manière très agile et
flexible aux services de sauvetage
public une école dédiée à la
cybersécurité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son nom
l'école de 1600 à l'ouvrir à ses portes
en septembre 2021
et pour cette première année elle
accueillera une centaine d'apprenants
qui seront formés aux métiers de la
cyber sécurité
un domaine en pleine croissance et qui a
besoin de compétences les détails dans
cette interview express d'axel dreyfus
le cofondateur de l'école de 1600
[Musique]
l'école de 1600 est une école en
alternance qui vise à informer les cyber
défenseur en l'école ouvrira normalement
le 13 septembre dans l'ancien musée de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
dans le 78 la première partie
enseignement en présence à l'école
deuxième partie enseignement à distance
troisième partie présent sur
l'entreprise ce sera un titre de niveau
7 qui équivaut à bac +5 avec un titre
d'experts en gestion des systèmes
sécurité informatique
[Musique]
on estime qu'il faudra horizon 2025
avoir 45 mille postes dont trente mille
sont vacants partons maintenant à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici au
sein de la société antemeta spécialisés
dans la cybersécurité
elle vient d'inaugurer ses nouveaux
locaux 420 m² dédiés à la cyber sécurité
et à la protection des données
numériques et à la clé une vague
importante de recrutement
[Musique]
antemeta ses 180 collaborateurs à saint
quentin en yvelines une société créée en
1995 et elle vient de franchir une
nouvelle étape avec cette espace de 420
m² pour en parler nous sommes avec
stéphane bern le président et fondateur
d'antemeta bonjour bonjour
je
ça y est on rentre dans une nouvelle
phase de développement de l'enceinte de
la société
alors en fait on dans cet espace on va
traiter la sécurité de nos systèmes
d'information de nos clients qui ont des
activités cloud services managés
antemeta c'est effectivement 180
personnes ici mais c'est aussi 280
personnes dans l'eau dans l'ensemble du
groupe cet espace ne pourrait plus cheap
de converger à la fois notre activité de
cyber sécurité
d'accord avec notre stock est nôtre et
notre note et notre activité de
protection des données
d'accord parce que en fait la
problématique aujourd'hui que
rencontrent nos clients c'est pas c'est
pas si ils vont se rate à quai quel que
soit des moyens qu'ils mettent en termes
de cybersécurité ces camps est donc
l'intérêt de converger la protection de
la donner et la cybersécurité ça à tous
on retrouve qu'un espace quelles vont
être les missions de chaque bureau de
chaque espace qu'on retrouve ici tu as
le noc qui est qui est derrière toi bien
évidemment ultra sécurisé tu as les
espaces ici qui sont pour la production
et l'exploitation de cloud d'accord ce
qu'on appelle le soc d'accord qui sont
présents ici on a aussi des espaces de
coworking puisqu'en fait quand on
accoste des clients ou quand on évolue
le cloud de nos clients il faut faire
travailler ce qu'on appelle le bild et
lawrence et les équipes qui vont
déployer récupérer le les
infrastructures et à tempérer les dates
à des clients et qui ont les rapatriés
chez nous d'accord il faut les faire
travailler avec nos équipes qui germent
trois clochetons c'est la convergence
trefis synthèse de guerre aussi parce
qu'il ya une war zone il ya une loi room
voilà warzone war room effectivement
leur bien évidemment tu évites pour ma
barque latine en tant que patron de la
boîte
moi je vais l'utiliser et mieux je vais
porter la war room c'est vraiment
un espace qui complètement qui peut être
complètement détruit un temps de thèmes
de son toit l'interdisent ul parce qu'on
est dans une situation extrêmement
critique et qu'il faut travailler d'une
façon extrêmement serré c'est en cas d'
pour préciser à nos téléspectateurs ac
en cas de grosse attaque une grosse
crise sur un de vos clients c'est là où
vous aller contrer cette attaque qui a
une ampleur quand même assez conséquent
l'emploi qui dit c'est une équipe dédiée
qui travaille travaille là dessus qu'ils
en corrélation avec les autres équipes
mais qui est concentré uniquement sur ce
sujet qui doit pas être pollué par par
autre chose c'est les groupes d'élite un
peu d'antenne et arak hautement
exactement c'est un groupe d'élite
un dernier mot stéphane sur ce projet le
projet qui aboutit aussi à de nouveaux
recrutements vous recherchez des
collaborateurs en ce moment voir plus
d'une cinquantaine de personnes
bien évidemment c'est l'objectif de
recrutement de 2000 internautes et bêta
et justement on va rejoindre arnaud
fuentes votre directeur des ressources
humaines pour approfondir ce sujet
[Musique]
et nous avons rejoint arnaud fuentes de
directeur des ressources humaines
d'antemeta bonjour ma jolie colin alors
vous êtes en plein recrutement de
nouveaux collaborateurs
quel type de profil vous recherchez
effectivement sur l'année 2021 nous
recrutons 55 nouveaux collaborateurs
il s'agit de profils juniors confirmé
également seniors nous sommes sur les
métiers phares d'antemeta qui répondent
à des expertises l'infrastructure le
réseau la cybersécurité la donne et qui
sont dépliés extrêmement importante pour
un des mythes à un cycle partie plate
forme et solution c'est qu'elles nous
montrent leur mission en fait
concrètement on va parler de des métiers
de chefferie de projets donc chef de
projet des services delivery manager
mais également des ingénieurs des avant
ventes en termes de politique de
ressources humaines ce que nous faisons
c'est que nous recrutons des jeunes qui
sont en alternance donc une formation au
sein d'écoles et qui se forment
également chez nous à nos métiers à nos
pratiques et ça nous permet ensuite
d'embaucher ces jeunes et d'en faire les
nouveaux talents dans tes amis tu as un
dernier mot c'est sur cette nouvelle
politique aussi qui fait partie de votre
politique de responsabilité sociale et
environnementale alors avec le volet
social
vous mettez à disposition des logements
antemeta acheter des logements pour les
mettre à disposition de ses
collaborateurs
effectivement nous innovons avec l'achat
de logements et ces logements vont
permettre à nos collaborateurs en région
de venir plus facilement sur notre siège
à guyancourt et également de pouvoir
accueillir héberger temporairement des
alternants qui voudraient faire d'une
alternance chez nous et trouver un
logement à proximité
c'est quelque chose s'est vraiment
d'innovant comme vous l'avez dit c'est
du social c'est ça participe au bien
être de vos collaborateurs cdh à
proximité
antemeta antemeta souhaite faciliter la
relation au travail de leurs
collaborateurs
et aujourd'hui nous pensons qu
effectivement mettre à proximité des
logements
pour nos collaborateurs est un avantage
merci arnaud fuentes bien c'est nicolas
le directeur des ressources humaines
d'antemeta et avant de conclure cette
émission notée le rendez vous de
l'innovation de paris saclay spring aura
lieu le 20 et 21 mai prochains à l'école
normale supérieure de paris saclay si
vous êtes une potée une pme wind start
up vous pouvez vous inscrire sur le site
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission
émission à revoir en ripé sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
m